tu peux le laisser défiler en travelling
légèrement hâlé pas latéral a alors
3 ok ça va tomber on trouve ça est-ce
qu'on peut passer au dessus de ces
collines en étant relativement verticale
les ans tout simple c'est que
vraisemblablement autour de l'os haïti
sans fera la même chose de bain ce coupé
voilà c'est bien la vraie voix comme
cela c'est bien ce pas là bas tactile et
plus je sais pas si tu peux les attire
bien comme ça où on y pêche cependant
pas quand on a juste un de relier parce
que dalle soleil dans le dos quoi voilà
les ont portés sans dans l'axé alors on
va pas de relief du tout quoi d'accord
dont je vais pas bon pour toi tu trouves
je sais pas et on va pas tellement de
retrouver du relief fois de pas beaucoup
je perds tu as raison on s'est dit qu'en
même temps dure dix secondes encore mais
avant de le prendre sous un autre angle
hockey
ok on coupe dans cette double attaque à
100 pips swiss lotto
pas mal pas et faisant plonger encore
cette fois un hymne guerrier un hockey
en coupe partout ça va un peu lent un
plan un peu lente en europe
il faut faire la même chose là même
genre de chose toi avec les montagnes et
la vallée comme ça là bas est couvert de
verre le contrat sera marquée quoi
d'alu bien ça va pour toi on est un peu
pourri là tu penses quoi devant la cour
ok on repère passage non c'était bien
pour tous l'autre axe donne alors qui
pousse des seins je veux y revient un
peu à droite encore poker radio fm et
peut-être avec un peu plus de
perspectives le fond bombe à bord dont
la sur l'autre on va rouler sur l'autre
aux hackers pas là on voit pas trop le
voyage ou quoi non plus le prêt bon un
bâtonnet revenus pas latéral on est
presque deux faces voix d'alison des
arbres et sont passés dans notre dos
c'est pas mal comme ça et bien contre sa
marque plus ah bon on peut se tourner
après un retour de l'autre côté vous
voulez on peu la honte qui s'est coupé
voit la faille à tiflet encore pelé à la
clé ça c'est assez beau comme fin à la
fab alsace il où ça ouais ouais les
autres belles couleurs la saison assez
douces en plus soit pas toujours y
retravailler facilement celle là c'est
bien ça presque pas mal ça car des
projets tanguy parce que si l'on a
affaire qui est un petit frère au milieu
un peu vicieux
bon il vient à temps les signes la
caisse est là dessus reste en seconde
bon écoute c'est bien parce que il
vraiment ça a été ok piot jackass est
habituel ouais ok